Some of you may have thought of this
already, and that is, prior to P two getting
its lock, it is possible that maybe another processor,
say P three, also used the same lock. And
so, when it executed its critical section, maybe in
its critical section, it modified the page X again,
and it creates its own def, let's call it
Xd prime. Because all of these locks are the
same, When, the DSM software knows that now there are two difs associated with
this lock, L, one dif is with the processor P one, and another dif is residing
with processor P three, and therefore when processor P two tries to access x
The DSM software has not only to get the diff from P one, but it also needs
to get the diff from P two and apply it to the original, pristine
version of the page that is with the owner of the page so that it can create
the current version of the page. And it
can extend this to any number of processors.
That may have made modifications, their own modifications,
to this page under the provision of the
lock L. All of those diffs are going to be applied in order for the process of P
two to access the page as the current page. If after accessing the page
x and its execution P two. Touches let's say page Z at that point once again
the [INAUDIBLE] knows that, oh, I know that
Z was modified by the previous lock holder
Zd is the diff I know where to find it I'll bring the original copy of z from...
The owner of Z and apply the diffs to
it before letting P two access Z. So you can
see, that even though the invalidation was done right
at the beginning, we're procrastinating getting the this til
the point of access. So this is what LRC
allows you to do is just bring in what this
guy needs. So for instance, inside this critical
section maybe only X is accessed. Y and
Z are not accessed at all, in which case, we never bring the diffs from P one
to P two for y and z.P two On the other hand, it is possible that P
two, as part of its execution of its
critical section. Modifies another page Q, different from X,
Y, and Z. So now, the DSM software knows that this particular lock is associated
not just with X, Y, and Z, but it is also associated with Q. So future lock
request for L will result in invalidating X, Y, Z, and Q because all of those
may have been modified and the next critical
section that wants to access this lock L has
to get the current versions of all the pages that were ever associated with L.